that we didn't have a chance to actually
make any attempt to stop them because
there wasn't enough time this is a video
of a 95 year old Korean War veteran his
name is Frank tomorrow talking about how
the services that he's been given 95
year old U.S vet are being cut okay he
is being pushed out of his nursing home
because they're using it for
undocumented workers this video went
viral and everyone should know this
guy's name and we will look into into
helping him take a look at this but the
point of all of this of course is that
once you say oh we want everyone to come
here we're going to give you stuff we
don't have unlimited stuff and then what
do you do you literally punish our
veterans and our taxpayers and the good
decent citizens of the United States
with this BS policy
it was very disgraceful what they did to
the people in Island Shores
they gave us
time to get out but they never said when
and they never said they will go and get
in the South and then one day
there's a thing on the board I know the
Son of God you gotta be out by March
15th I think that gave us like a month
and a half to find out where we're going
to go
I told my suitcases were going to be on
the curve because I'm not that pissed it
wasn't for my daughter they would have
been on the Curve
but that's what it happened and uh
that was it
I said no no no no you're not moving me
and they said yes yes yes we are and it
everything was done behind closed doors
yeah and we didn't have a chance to
actually make any attempt to stop them
because there wasn't enough time I
I don't even know what to say about that
first off God bless that guy we will if
anyone knows how to get in touch with
him my guess is there's a GoFundMe for
him or something can we could we look
into that after the show
um I mean just absolutely evil and
disgusting 95 years old the fact that
guy still has a smile on his face and
God bless his daughter for taking care
of him I'm sure he's gonna it sounds
like he will be okay but there are there
are probably thousands and thousands of
other veterans and it's not just the
veterans it's the hotel owner it's it's
the guy who honestly pays his rent who
is now in a building with these people
and the crime that will expand because
of all that